مساء الخير في اللحظه انا بتكلم حضراتكم
فيها يوجد ست دول تعيش الدول العربيه تعيش
على صفيح ساخن في انتظار لحظه انتقال
السلطه من الحاكم الحالي الحاكم التالي
هذه الدول هي مصر والسودان والجزائر
وموريتانيا والسعوديه وسلطنه عمان كل دوله
من دول لها ظروف مختلفه لكن القاسم
المشترك هو صعوبه لحظه انتقال السلطه اه
المنتظره اذا بدانا بمصر هلا ان وصل بتعيش
مازق واضح جدا المازق ده مش موجود على
الورق على الورق مفيش مشكله لكن الورق لا
يعبر عن الحقيقه الحقيقه بتقول نحنا قدام
سيناريوهين السيناريو الاول هو ان يلتزم
الرئيس الحالي عبد الفتاح السيسي بالدستور
يغادر السلطه في يونيو اثنين وعشرين يعني
بعد حوالي ثلاث سنوات ونصف وفي الحاله دي
سيكون مصر قدام مازق بسيط جدا انه مع غياب
الاحزاب مع غياب الحياه السياسيه مع غياب
الحياه السياسيه الناشطه وبالتالي
المعارضه لا يوجد بدائل واضحه قدام الشعب
المصري يمكن ان يختار منها وفي الحاله دي
اذا غادر الرئيس سيكون السيناريو المتوقع
ان القوات المسلحه اللي هي عمود الخيمه في
المجتمع المصري او الدوله المصريه يقع
عليها عبء انهى تشجع او ترشح او تسمح لاحد
افرادها او احد ال محسوبين عليها او احد
الذين تبارك و و في الغالب يكون جنرال
سابق او حالي انه هو يتولى السلطه او
يترشح وبالتالي تدعمه وتدعمه الدوله ويقع
على الاعلام
تقديم والى المواطنين واي مرشحين اخر
حيكونوا مجرد وبالتالي يكون مازق الان
احنا في الحاله دي نحنا فاجابه اثنين
وعشرين وهل شعبها يقبل المرشح الوحيد بحكم
الضروره
لا يكون يعني اه مطروح
الاختيار الثاني يكون اصعب او السيناريو
الثاني اكثر صعوبه وهو انه الرئيس
يقرر او يقبل او يسمح او يساهم باي شكل من
الاشكال في فكره فتح الدستور وتغيير هذه
الدعوات اللي هي بدات مؤخرا في اعمده وعلى
صفحات بعض الجرائد
تمهيدا للفكره ك بالون اختبار وكانت مثار
للحديث خلال ال الايام الاخيره على الساحه
المصريه
صعوبه هذا الاختيار انه يضع مصر قدام
سيناريوهات مفتوحه جدا يعني اولا تغيير
الدستور في حد ذاته معناها يكون نهايه
يعني كل امال عدد كبير جدا خصوصا من
الشباب اللي شاركوا في الحياه السياسيه
اللي فتره من يناير والى الان في اي اي
امل تبخر اي امل في يعني حياه سياسيه
مقبوله و انتقال السلطه بشكل سلس لكن حتى
بعيدا عن هذا الكلام
انا قدام مازق كبير يعني يعني تغيير
الدستور دا معناه انه يعني يسمحوا له
بفتره ما تم تغيير الدستور في الغرب يكون
لفتره اكثر من فتره لفتره هل ان المشكله
وتتاجل لمده اربع سنوات او خمس سنوات
قادمه لو لفترات ان اجد نفسي قدام سنرى
واجبه ما تم ايام الرئيس مبارك اللي بقى
في السلطه تسعه وعشرين سنه وكان فيه حاله
التكلف ورود شديد جدا وانتهت المساله بغضب
وثوره يبقى احنا قدام سيناريو الثاني
السؤال لو كنت انا اقدم المشهوره من عده
الشرعيه في البرنامج لا اشرت على الرئيس
بالاكتفاء
لفترتين رئاسيتين و احترام الدستور اذا
فعل ذلك سوف يدخل الرئيس السياسي التاريخ
من اوسع ابوابه في 2014 و 2013 كانت شعبيه
الرئيس السيسي جارفه من عدد كبير من
المواطنين
لاسباب يطول شرحها باستثناء شريحه واحده
من المجتمع المصري وهي معظم التيارات
الاسلاميه خصوصا ان جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين لاسباب النفط
لما دخل السلطه اضاف لخصومه شريحه اخرى
اما من المعترضين على سياساته وخصوصا
سياسات الاصلاح الاقتصادي او من النخبه
المعترضه على سياساته العامه سواء
الاقتصاديه او
سياساته اللي بتتعلق ب اه اه
الحريات العامه
كبت الحريات العامه لكن بيظل الى شريحه
واسعه من المؤيدين واللي شايفين انه الرجل
عمل انجازات اه يعني وان كانت محل خلاف
بين الناس لكن عنده شريحه كبيره هو عنده
انجازات كبيره اذا غادروا السلطه سوف يشكل
الرئيس على ما قدم من انجازات وما لم يقدم
اما اذا بقي
فسوف يتم تحميل المسؤولين على كل الاخطاء
اللي ارتكبتها وحتى الاخطاء التي لم
يرتكبها وهم وهناك المصري تتدخل في
سيناريو يعني زي ما بقول لحضرتك مع يكون
اقرب الى سيناريو سنوات الغضب والاحباط في
سنوات ال فيما يتعلق بالسودان اللي تكلمت
على السودان في حلقه ووضع الرئيس البشير
اصعب لان الرئيس البشير
في السلطه موجود في السلطه منذ تسعه
وعشرين سنه او ثمانيه وعشرين سنه ثمانيه
وعشرين وتسعه وعشرين يحسبوها من سنه تسعه
وثمانين والمشكله في الرئيس البشير انه هو
في مازق والشعب السوداني ايضا في مازق
الشعب السوداني في مادبه المازق اللي
موجود في المصريين وهو انه خلال تسعه
وعشرين سنه
يعني نجح الرئيس البشير في انه هو يضعف كل
الاحزاب التقليديه القويه سواء المدنيه او
الامه او يعني طبعا الحزب الشيوعي حزب نشط
ولكن شعبيه وليست واسعه وبالتالي وكثير من
الرموز يعني غادرت البلد
وبالتالي البديل او لاحظه التغيير في
السودان بالوضع الراهن ليست مستحيله
ولكنها باتت صعبه وفي نفس الوقت هو
بالنسبه له يعني راهي من سلامته الشخصيه
والاطمئنان على مستقبله مستقبله اسرته في
التحسن بالسلطه لانه هو المطالبه من جانب
ال محكمه الجنايات الجنائيه الدوليه
لارتكاب وفق الاتهام بارتكاب جرائم حرب في
دارفور
بردو مره ثانيه يعني اذا بقيت في السلطه
لمده تسعه وعشرين او ثلاثين سنه
فكره تلميحات بالترشح في سنه الفين وعشرين
وهو في سن الاربعه وسبعين ربنا
يبقى في السلطه كان سنه يعني مده كمان ثم
تتجدد المشكله متين ولا مدى الحياه انت
يعني يكون المحكمه الواضح جدا في حاله
الرئيس البشير ورؤساء عرب اخرين انه لحظه
الدخول بتبقى محسوبه بدقه يعني
سنه تسعه وثمانين كانت المساله محسومه
بدقه انقلابه على الحكومه اه السابقه
المحكمه لكن لحظه الخروج بتبقى مش مطروحه
وهذه الازمه والمشكله الكبيره وبالتالي
السودان سوف يظل مع كل السيناريوهات
الموجوده خصوصا مع عدم الوصول رساله الشعب
السوداني لفخامه الرئيس وبالتالي هو حتى
الان غير مقتنع اللي بيصر في الشارع هؤلاء
يرفضون نظامه بيعتبروا منهم متامرين وخانه
مدفوعين من الخارج السودان هي يعيش فتره
ايضا صعبه جدا في لحظه انتقال السلطه اذا
كان بشكل لسمح الله عنيفا وطبعا كما نتمنى
يكون بشكل سلمي وده لن ياتي الا بمبادره
من الرئيس البشير القصه احنا تكلمنا ايضا
على الجزائر الجزائر مشكلتها تختلف
اختلافا يعني واضحه لكن في جوهرها فيه
مشكله في لحظه انتقال السلطه من الرئيس
بوتفليقه الى الرئيس القادم الرئيس
بوتفليقه
يعلم القاسم الداني شفاه الله غير قادر
الان على ممارسه مهام سلطته لكن يبدو ان
الرجل والقوى المحيطه واصحاب اللي بيقول
عليه من ستكون اصحاب المصلحه الاساسيه
يعني والباس اذا كانت القوات المسلحه او
المقربين من الرئيس او شقيق الرئيس او
يعني ال النافدين في السلطه كلهم في حاجه
بدي اربعين بيشتروا وقتا علشان يرتبوا
الاوضاع بشكل يقلل فرص النزاع على خلافه
الرئيس بوتفليقه ازاي المساله الذي يمكن
ان تنتهي ايضا احنا في انتظار اختيارات
صعبه بس الاختيارات دي نتيجه عدم وضوح في
الرؤيه يعني لو كانت المساله طرح بينما
كان الرئيس يعني من كامل صفحاتها وسلامته
وكانت في اختيارات وعمليه تداول السلطه
واضحه وفيه اختيارات وهي دعمها القوات
المسلحه
ويرعاها الرئيس بين ما هو قابض على الامور
كانت الامور الكثير في الجزائر
تسير الامور في موريتانيا الوضع ان تكلمنا
بردو عنه قبل كده في حلقه اه اه يعني ملوك
يحكمون الجمهوريات انه ال ال ال الرئيس
الحالي في موريتانيه يرغب في ولايه ثانيه
في ولايه ثالثه لكن يبدو
انه هو وكندا قد ينطبق ايضا على الرئيس
البشير قد ينطبق ايضا على الرئيس المصري
يبدو انهم بيفكروا في خيار اخر ممكن يكون
بديلا عن تعديل الدستور وهو خيار
يعني ان يبقى ان يخرج من السلطه على ان
يتم اختيار شخص اخر وهذا الشخص الاخر يقوم
بدور المحلل اللي هو يجري السلطه
في روسيا وبالتالي بعد فتره انتهاء ولايته
الثانيه يعود الرئيس بشكل او باخر الى
السلطه يعني كبديل على فكره مغادره السلطه
وفي نفس الوقت احترام الدستور
ما في السعوديه
فال قصه بسيطه جدا يفترض انه فيه ملكيه
وفي الملكيه ولي العهد دخول الملك القادم
بس المشكله زي ما كل السعوديين وكل العالم
باعتبار انه الشان السعودي اهم العالم كله
انه الامير محمد بن سلمان يواجه عده عوائق
كبيره جدا يعني الطريق ليس موحدا له كما
كان مما حدا الولاء لولاد اول مرا سابقين
كانوا يتولون ولايه العهد السبب الاول
يعني زي ما الجميع يعرف انه تم اختياره
على حساب اخرين كانوا اقرب الى ولايه
العهد منهم
وبالتالي هو عنده فيه نوع من الخصومه داخل
او فيه نوع من التحفظ او في يعني عدم
تسليم كامل باهليته يتولى السلطه من جانب
بعض المسؤولين في الاسره لكن في وجود
الملك اطال الله في عمره ما فيش مشكله حتى
هذه اللحظه اذا انتقلت السلطه اذا اذا بدا
يفكروا في انتقال السلطه بعد وفاه الملك
اه اه
جلاله الملك بيبقى في الحاله اوليه او
خادم الحرمين يبقى في هذه الحاله قد تصور
بعض المشاكل خصوصا بعد مقتل الصحفي اللي
هي اضعف اه الكثير من اه
فرص تاييد وحماس قوى غربيه لولي العهد
لاتهامهم بمسؤولياتها مقتل كما الخ شكليه
وبالتالي يكون في مساله الصعوبه لا توجد
استحاله ولكن توجد صعوبه وهذه الصعوبه هي
التي تشكل الان الجوهر او السبب الرئيسي
لقرارات في الكثير من القرارات صانع
القرار في المملكه لانه بياخذ في اعتبارات
عده امور ومنها التمهيد السلف
لانتقال السلطه لولي العهد محمد بن سلمان
وهو يكون اول ملك في السعوديه يتولى
السلطه وهو في
هي في مقتبل الامور
النقطه الاخيره اللي احنا تكلمنا عليها
قبل كده ايضا سلطنه عمان سلطنه عمان
الاخوه العمانيين لا اعتقد ان هناك مشكله
ولكنها يتكون الدوله الوحيده في العالم
السلطان
يجمع في يد كل السلطات كل السلطات بما
فيها البنك المركزي وزاره الماليه ووزاره
الدفاع كل السلطات مع شفاه الله من
معاناته لمتاعب صحيه جمه منذ عده سنوات
وفي نفس الوقت اسم الخليفه الذي يرشحه
السلطان موجود في ورقه داخل خزينه في
القصر السلطاني وانه هذه الورقه سوف يكشف
عنها بعد وفاه السلطان وبالتالي بعد ان
فرض السلطان قابوس وبعد ان تبقى محل يتم
استفتاء الناس عليها او يتم ال لكن هذا
رغم ان الكل منا على الورق يعني انها لا
توجد مشكله فانتقل الخلافه لكن المدينه
جدا اذا كانت هناك مشاكل في الدول اللي
بيتم فيها ال يعني انتقال السلطه في بشكل
جمهوري او من خلال او حتى في شكل ما لكن
كما في حاله السعوديه لكم ان تتخيلوا انه
ايضا السلطنه التي لا يوجد فيه الان خصوصا
مع كثره المتنافسين داخل الاسره وعدد كثير
من المرشحين اه كيف يمكن ان يكون الحال
عند وفاه السلطان قابوس اه يعني بردو يعني
نسال الله يطول الامر والشفاء اكيد ان
يكون في نفس القصه تعيش السلطنه السلطنه
صعبه في اختيار المنافس تكون للتدخلات
الخارجيه دور كبير والاهم من كل ده انه
القادم الجديد
هل هي يتبع نفس السياسات اللي انقذت
السلطنه من صعوبات جمه من لديه السبعينات
والى الان ام سوف ياخذها في مسار اخر
اشكركم والى لقاء اخر باذن الله
ام
[موسيقى]